Herzlich willkommen, sehr geehrte Damen und Herren, zur Podcast-UFO-Show aus dem milden Norden. Heute der Mittwochtalk, der einzige Wochentag, wo das Wortspiel nicht funktioniert. Stefan Stitze ist auch da, cooler Mann, guter Mann. Hallo Florentin Will. Die Leute lieben ihn, die Kommentare laufen jedes Mal heiß, wenn er hier zu Gast ist. Bam, bam, bam. Zum 73. Mal steht er hier mir gegenüber und weiß nicht so recht, was er sagen will, hat zwei Festplatten in der Hand, man weiß nicht genau warum. Hat auf jeden Fall eine Menge Gags mitgebracht, aber keine Möglichkeit, sie anzuschauen. Die Situation ist folgende. Wir wollten seit zwei Stunden aufnehmen, wir haben es nicht geschafft, mal wieder haben wir technische Probleme. Obwohl, ich kann es nicht oft genug betonen, wir jede Woche das gleiche Setup haben. Wir wissen nicht genau, woran es liegt, mittlerweile haben wir ein Rauschen auf dem Interface, aber mit unseren 20.000 Spotify-Money können wir jetzt ordentlich investieren, um ein bisschen was mal gucken, vielleicht ein neues Interface, irgendwas, wir gönnen uns mal was, Interface einfach. Diese Wünsche, die man als Jugendlicher hat. Heute wird eine kurze Folge, weil wir müssen beide weg, wir haben beide keine Zeit und vor allem keine Lust. Vor allem keine Lust. Ich sag mal so, das Podcast-UFO-Projekt ist abgehoben und es gibt ja irgendwie ... Ist das bei uns gut oder schlecht? Das klingt eigentlich ganz gut.
Das ist ein bisschen die Frage.
Erzähl mal was, was dich so bewegt. Du meinst, du wolltest zwar die ernste Folge aufnehmen, du wolltest ernst fragen, was mich umtreibt, du wolltest was ernstes, du wolltest mal den Mensch-Tieze kennenlernen, genau wie ich den Mensch will kennenlernen will.
Und ich denke, das ist prächtigt. Wir wollen nicht immer diese Tweets bekommen mit, wir haben uns in der U-Bahn schlapp gelacht, wir wollen auch mal, wir haben in der U-Bahn angefangen zu weinen, wir haben in der U-Bahn angefangen nachzudenken, wir haben nachdenken, aus dem Fenster geguckt, wir haben das Handy weggelegt, wir haben aus dem Fenster geguckt, in die Wolken und haben da philosophische Fragen gesehen.
Ich glaube, wir können das gar nicht. Wir schreiben momentan recht viel.
Bücher, also traurige Romane.
Mir zumindest fällt es immer sehr schwer, wenn gewisse Sachen ernste und lustige Komponenten haben.
Dann scheitere ich gnadenlos an den ernsten Komponenten und denke mir dann, okay, gut, ich kann nichts anderes als lustig sein und mal so eine ernste Kurzgeschichte schreiben kann ich nicht. Du hingegen, von dir habe ich schon einige absolut imposante Kurzgeschichten gesehen, Stefan ist ja ein sehr umtriebiger Mensch, was Kreativität angeht, der geht nach Hause und dann kann er sich nicht entscheiden, nehm ich den Früchtetee oder spiele ich heute auf der Posaune, spiele ich auf meinem E-Bass, spiele ich auf meinem Akustik-Bass, baue ich weiter an meinem AT-ST-Sammelband. Worauf wolltest du genau mit dieser Endlosschleife an Mini-Mini-Gates? Immer diese Scheissworte. Immer diese Scheissworte. Nee, dass du einfach sehr umtriebig bist irgendwie. Also du verhedderst dich in vielen verschiedenen kreativen... Aber die sind ja nicht ernst. Ich verstehe mich mittlerweile nicht mehr als Komödiant. Ich würde mich auch mal so ein bisschen als Unterhalter wahrnehmen. Einfach der hier auch mal und auch ernste Sachen können durchaus unterhaltsam sein. Und das würde ich dir auch raten, mich nicht mal da mal in die Richtung so ein bisschen, weiss ich nicht, auch so von Selbstempfindung, von der Selbstwirklichung hinzuarbeiten, nicht nur der Quatschkopf zu sein. Weil, ganz ehrlich, du landest in einer Endlosstreife. Immer Quatsch geht nicht, immer Quatsch und dich mit Quatsch Leuten umgeben, so Posaunen, Knallköpfe wie mir, das ist nicht gut. Dann bist du in deiner Spirale gefangen und dann kommst du nicht mehr raus, du brauchst das richtige Leben. Du musst auch mal mit einem Obdachlosen sprechen.
Habe ich noch nicht gesagt, einfach mal das Leben kennenlernen, auf die Strasse gehen.
Du musst auch mal abends ein bisschen länger auf der Party bleiben, um zu Party bleiben, um zu gucken, wie die Leute so reden und was sie so zu sagen haben, was die Haltung ist.
Comedy ist Haltung und keine Haltung, das ist wirklich ein Problem, wirklich sauer bin ich darüber, dass wir keine Haltung transportieren können, weil wir da nicht so Menschen sind. Komm, die braucht keine Haltung. Komm, die ist Haltung, nur Haltung. Nee. Klar, um was ironisch sagen zu können, musst du ja eine Haltung haben. Ja, was heißt eine Haltung? Eine Meinung. Ja, aber du brauchst keine Meinung. Eine lustige Meinung, lustiger Einfall. Das sind alles Haltungen. Verschobene Haltungen, verschobene. Der alte Mann, der krebsdurchflutete Mann, der auf der Eisfläche ausrutscht, der hat keine Haltung. Und da kann ich laut drüber lachen. Wegen Haltungsnote jetzt. Ich bin aber auch einfach energieleveltechnisch gerade ganz am Boden. Wir haben den ganzen Tag gedreht, drehen ist einfach mega Kräftezern. Und ich bin genau das Gegenteil. Ja, das ist echt ein Problem. Ich möchte kurz fünf Getränke aufzählen, die ich heute zu mir genommen habe.
Fünf Getränke zu mir genommen.
Ich fing an mit einem Kaffee, dann habe ich eine Club Mate getrunken, dann einen schwarzen Tee, dann eine Cola und jetzt bin ich übergegangen zu Red Bull. Das sind fünf Getränke, ich habe eine Red Bull und das sind fünf Getränke, die mich alle wach machen und ich kann jetzt in der Nacht, ich kann die nächsten drei nicht glaube ich nicht schlafenfen und ich bin gerade so, ich war eben nach der Aufzeichnung drüben beim
Neo-Magazin, kommen ja alle mal so
zusammen und wir sind normalerweise nicht die Menschen,
die dann immer noch ewig bis in die Puppen
da bleiben, aber ich habe heute mit
jedem gesprochen und habe
jedes Gespräch wahrnehmen können, wie so
Spider-Mans-Sinne, wurden geschärft einfach
und ich habe überall alles wahrgenommen, alles war
viel lauter, ich habe überall mitgeredet
und viel zu schnell und sowas, das war echt, das ist echt nicht gut wenn man so viel. Deswegen finde ich auch nicht gut, dass ich jetzt mit so einem Schlafsack hier konfrontiert bin. Dieser typischen. Ja, es tut mir leid, ich bin müde einfach. Ne, W.O.W., oder? Ist es W.O.W.? Ja, es ist auch W.O.W., es ist Schlafanzug von allen Seiten. Schlafanzug? Och Mann. Mensch, ey, Florentin. Ne, komm. So funktioniert es doch nicht. Ich habe da keinen Bock drauf. Ich möchte, dass du glücklich bist. Ja, ich bin ja glücklich. Ich bin zu glücklich, das ist das große Problem. Ich habe momentan nichts mehr, ich habe kein Rand-Potenzial in mir, ich kann nicht mehr sagen, weißt du, da ist mir letztens, da stand ich an der Kasse und dann hat er das Kundendifferenzierungsmodul da hingelegt und ich und ich schaue auf sowas und denke mir, oh mein Gott, ist doch scheisse gar nicht, ich bin zu glücklich, ich bin zufrieden, ich habe alles, ich habe einen tollen Job, ich habe tolle Freunde, ich brauche nicht mehr viel im Leben. Aber das ist ja auch eine fehlende Haltung, also vor allem Körperhaltung bei dir, aber es ist auch eine fehlende Haltung im Supermarkt, das nicht mehr als lustigen Einfall wahrzunehmen, dann hast du jetzt einfach eine neue Haltung, du bist einfach jetzt so ein Langweiler. Ja, ich bin wirklich ein Langweiler geworden, das stimmt.
Aber Langweiler machen keine Comedy, Langweiler machen Langeweile vor allem.
Ja.
Und das will sich niemand anhören.
Vielleicht fangen wir einfach nochmal an mit dem Musical.
Oder mit einem Intro. Seitdem wir kein Intro mehr haben, ist es Bergabergang, oder?
Das stimmt, ja, obwohl man die Aufnahmesituation eigentlich keinen Unterschied macht.
Hier in meinem Koffer habe ich das immer abgespielt, das Intro. Echt? Ja, aber in der Reggae-Version. Das ist der Trick, glaube ich. Das macht es ein bisschen lustiger. Warum ist Reggae so scheiße? Das ist eine Haltung. Jetzt hast du mal deine Scheiss-Haltung. Das ist nicht schlecht. Das ist gut, Florian, wir nähern uns langsam wieder Comedy-Potential. Wartet noch so sieben Minuten, dann sind wir da. Ich Ich finde Reggae kommt auch an, wo man ist. Also am Strand finde ich Reggae cool. Da ich aber nie am Strand bin. Genau, es ist meistens uncool. So bei Beachpartys und so. Keine Ahnung, wo man die erleben kann, wo es die gibt. Aber wenn man eine Beachpartys mal erleben würde, dann so mitten in Köln fände ich auch Reggae cool. So ein bisschen Beach, ein bisschen Party, Beach Party. Ich habe, anders als du gehe ich doch mit offenen Augen durch die Welt und ich habe folgendes, folgendes erlebt. Ich habe, es ist keine Geschichte, es ist mehr ein Experiment jetzt. Ich bin mal gespannt, sowas hatten wir noch nie. Ich bin gestern an einer U-Bahn-Station gestanden und da war ein Mensch, der hatte ein Tattoo. Und es war ein Tattoo was man in der Aufmerksamkeit auf sich gelenkt hat und zwar waren es Koordinaten.
Und ich habe mir die auch abgeschrieben, weil ich wissen wollte, was das ist und ich habe
noch nicht nachgeguckt. Ich würde das gerne live mit euch nachgucken.
Kannst du die Koordinaten jetzt aussprechen oder wäre das dann Datenschutz, wenn du
Tattoos von anderen Menschen veröffentlichst?
Ja gut, er trägt sehr offen vor sich herum.
Naja gut, aber es ist ja trotzdem recht am eigenen Bild in einer gewissen Art.
Am eigenen Körper.
Am eigenen Wort vielleicht. Das habe ich mir auch gedacht, wenn du in der U-Bahn mitschreibst,
Das ist ein sehr guter, wenn du in der U-Bahn mitschreibst, was Leute sagen, ist das dann Urheberrechtsverletzung, wenn du das dann zum Beispiel als Buch veröffentlichst. Also haben die Leute ein Recht daran, was sie in der Öffentlichkeit sagen? Eigentlich nicht. Aber da sind diese ganzen Bücher, diese neumodischen, wo irgendeine Lehrerin über ihre tollen Erlebnisse als Mathematik-Genie spricht und mit ihren Erlebnissen von den Fieldklässern. Ha, die sind immer so lustig und ach, jeden Tag erlebt man tolle Sachen. Dann ist das alles verboten, ist alles illegal. Was glaubst du, was das für ein ... Ich suche gerade mal kurz raus. Und du sagst mal in der Zeit, was du glaubst, was das für ein Ort ist, den man sich eintätowieren lässt, ein Ort. Vielleicht ist das Tattoo-Studio, vielleicht ist es so eine Werbung für den Tattoo-Artist, der einfach sagt, okay, Leute, kommen zu mir, mach das, ich weiß es nicht, vielleicht ist es irgendein wichtiger Ort seines Lebens wahrscheinlich irgendwo, jemanden kennen, der vielleicht irgendein Reiseziel, irgendwas, wo er vielleicht einen Schatz versteckt hat oder sowas in der Richtung. Wäre eigentlich keine schlechte Idee, weil die Idee ist ja, dass man nach dem Tod dann einfach sich fragen würde, okay, was bedeutet das? Und wenn man dann hingehen, ich weiss gar nicht, wie man überhaupt Koordinaten sucht. Kannst du bei Google Maps einfach Koordinaten eingeben oder gibst du dir gerade den Taschenrechner ein oder was? Was stellst du dir jetzt da gerade vor? Ja, ich wollte jetzt die Quersumme bilden, dachte mir, kommt schon irgendwas raus. Ja, ja. Ne, ich finde es jetzt nicht genau raus. Hö, also, ja. Aber schon spannend. Also was ist das? Vielleicht der Geburtstag der Freundin oder so? Der Geburtstag, das wäre ja ein bisschen langweilig eigentlich, oder? Können wir nicht so Werbung noch einbauen? Mach mal Werbung für Fanta. Fanta, der erfrischend fruchtige Fruchtexplosionsgeschmack für dich und mich. Ciao! Selten enden Werbungen mit Ciao, weil man eigentlich unhöflich, nicht mal hallo, da sollen immer sagen die, hallo, mein Name ist Günther Greisler, oh, ich werde zuführen, die will. Selbst die Namen, die man sich ausdenkt, kommen schon von dir. Wir sind kreativ, sind wir schon zusammengezogen momentan, wir benutzen die Teller und Gabeln des anderen, wir haben einen Comedy-Haushalt. Aber wir machen nicht sauber, Wir müssen einmal so einen WG, so einen Putzplan müssen wir entwickeln. Das stimmt. Oh, soll ich eigentlich schon das große Geheimnis verraten? Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das rein datenschutzrechtlich erzählen darf, aber in meiner Wohnung ist etwas Unfassbares geschehen. Ich habe jemanden getroffen in meiner Wohnung und ich sage mal so, da kann ja vielleicht, sage ich mal, das Podcast-UforateRatespiel in eine neue Staffel gehen. Ich wohne seit mehreren Wochen, nicht zusammen, aber in dem Haus, in dem ich wohne, zwei Wohnungen unter mir, wohnt eine berühmte Person, die schon mal eine grössere Rolle im Podcast-Ufo-Universum gespielt hat. Und ich möchte nicht sagen, wer es ist, ich möchte aber sagen, ihr dürft euch bald auf eine Special-Folge freuen.
Ich möchte nur so viel anteasern, ich habe diese Person vor einer Woche im Treppenhaus das erste Mal gesehen und war komplett hin und weg. Und werde jetzt wahrscheinlich mit dieser Person mehr zu tun haben. Aber haben in der Treppenhaus-Geschichte jetzt, haben da Hundewelpen eine Rolle gespielt? Psst! Aber das ist so krass, ey. Ich möchte nicht zu viel verraten. Wofür hast du denn, in einem Willenviertel oder so?
Na ja, gut, man hat jetzt eins oder zwei.
Spotify hat man halt ein bisschen Geld.
YouTube-Money hat hier ja schon die Person, ohne zu viel zu machen.
Dafür habe ich Spotify-Money, was wesentlich weniger ist.
Dafür, dass wir es nicht sagen dürfen, dass wir nichts verdienen, sagen wir relativ häufig.
Seien wir relativ häufig, ja. Aber ich fand die Aussage von Spotify auch so gut, ja, ihr könnt bei uns mitmachen, aber die Teilnahme ist kostenlos.
Also, yes, geil.
Cool.
Cool. Das ist ja positiv. Und zwar, ich habe jetzt die Koordinaten eingegeben. Wie gut, wenn jetzt jetzt das Gebäude hier wäre, wir sind so, what the fuck? Das wäre ein Filmmoment. Das wäre geil. Christopher Nolan, mein Fuck, der nicht so richtig Sinn ergibt. Bäm, Nolan. Nolan. Schau mal ins Blende. Hakel, Toiletten, Papier. Weil es mittlerweile für alles mögliche benutzt wird. Ja, mach mal voran. Alsdorf bei Aachen, und zwar ein Naturschutzgebiet. Oh, Lane. Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee. Kennst du den Film The Signal? Ja. Da finden die auch Koordinaten, und das führt die halt zu Area 51. So, was ist das, wenn Alstorpe das deutsche Area 51 ist, wird er zu fucking Superhelden werden und dann hier zurückkehren und dann mit so tiefen Stimmen irgendwann anbieten zu moderieren? Wie Batman. Das ist eine interessante Frage. Aber warum hat er sich das tätowieren lassen? Was ist dort geschehen oder was wird dort noch geschehen? Und ich meine, das ist ja auch so eine Self-Fulfilling Prophecy. Du, glaube ich, einfach irgendwelche Koordinaten völlig wirklich, da wird irgendwas stattfinden, weil einfach die Erwartungshaltung selbst schon tolle Ereignisse erzeugt. Ja, was ist das eigentlich für ein Trend, der ist komplett an mir vorbeigegangen. Ich bin eigentlich ein Trend-Demens. Hallo? Ne, diese ISBN-Codes, diese Strich-Codes. QR-Codes? Nein, das ist der Vorgänger. Strich-Code. Ja, war so einfach. Im Hals. Das ist so ein riesen Trend. Im Hals, das ist gegen Husten. Ach so, hinten auf dem Nacken oder was? Hinten auf dem Nacken. Das ist vom Film Hitman. Da gibt es so, so, so, so Attentäter, so Mörder, Auftragskiller, die alle so einen Strich-Code haben. Aber das ist nicht von dem Film, oder? Doch. Das ist nicht so ein Freundschaftsbeweis, wurde mir mal gesagt. Wurde ich wieder verarscht. Wenn du mit Lidl befreundet bist oder was, oder wie soll das aussehen? Ja, mit Avocados, den neuen Avocados, die am Mord angekommen sind. Ich weiß nicht, also ich kenne das nur, das war ja ganz groß, auf der Werbekampagne stand das immer auf dem grossen Plakat für Hitman, war dieser Typ, der Timothy Olyphant, war abgebildet mit diesem Ding. Der lustigste Name der Welt. Ich muss ja immer lachen, wenn ich den Olyphant höre. Kann man sich aber echt gut merken. Das ist, glaube ich, für so einen Schauspieler gar nicht so dumm, ein bisschen lächerlichen Namen zu haben, damit du ihn ja einfach gut merken kannst. Das ist eigentlich gar nicht so dumm. Das ist ziemlich lustig. Hat Hitman nicht auch mal eine grosse Rolle in so einem Podcast gespielt? Beatman. Beatman war das. Beatman, ja, ja, Folge 17 bis
38. Ich wollte dich aufs Krossaue, aber Hitman und Beatman.
Diese ganz seltsame Stelle im Hitman 2,
wo plötzlich ein Rap losgeht.
Nee, aber ich glaube zum Beispiel, also
mit dieser Self-Fuffilling Prophecy, man kann ja
auch sagen, also ich sag jetzt mal,
dieses Jahr,
am 17. Oktober
wird was richtig
krasses geschehen. Okay? Haltet euch fest, achtet auf den 17. Oktober, die Welt wird nicht mehr dieselbe sein. An der Stelle sei euch gesagt, wird was richtig Krasses passieren. Okay, aber warum glaubst du, also glaubst du an die Existenz einer Self-Fulfilling-Prophecy? Also, glaubst du, wird jetzt etwas passiert? Weil natürlich passiert, jeden Tag passiert
etwas Krasses. Die Aussage ist ja jetzt per se nichts
Dramatisches in deinem Leben.
Alleine dadurch, dass Leute besonders
auf diesen Tag jetzt achten werden, mit unseren sieben Millionen
Hörern, wird sich durch Gruppendynamik
dort etwas passieren. Zum Beispiel, wenn ich
jetzt zum Beispiel sagen würde,
am 17. Oktober
wird in Hamburg auf dem
Eisenplatz um 18 Uhr was wirklich krasses passieren. Ja, es kann sein, dass du das SEK eingeschaltet hast. Hamburg, Alsenplatz, 17. Oktober, 18 Uhr. Und jetzt kommen schon mal zum Beispiel alle Podcast-Hörer, die dabei sein wollen bei diesem historischen Ereignis, kommen um 18 Uhr Hamburg, Alsenplatz. Unangemeldete, unangemeldete Menschenversammlung. Richtig, plötzlich ist der voll tausender Menschen. So, dann Massenpanik. Das erste unoffizielle Podcast-Uvo-Hörer-Treffen wird dort stattfinden und alle Leute kommen da hin und plötzlich entsteht da was und alle anderen Leute denken, oh, da ist irgendwas. Und dann sehen Leute, wie Florentin will, dabei war es nur so ein Obdachloser, der mal wieder besoffen Ruhig ging. Und dann sind alle wütend und sagen, oh, da ist ein Foto mit ihm und dann gibt es eine Schlägerei und dann passiert irgendwas und dann sagt man, ja gut, wenn wir jetzt eh schon, also ich meine, wir sind jetzt 10.000 Leute, wir können jetzt auch die Regierung stürzen. Wo wir jetzt eh schon mal hier sind. In Hamburg sind. Ja, dann stürzen wir halt den Bürgermeister von Hamburg. Fuck it, wir sind eh schon wach. Das wird nicht meine Newsday, glaube ich. Ich schlafe jetzt so schnell eh nicht mehr ein. Lass uns jetzt einfach nochmal dieses Arschloch aus seinem Palast zerren, was der uns alles eingebrockt hat. Fischbrötchen zehn Cent teurer. Was für eine Scheiße, der Lidl da hinten musste zumachen. Und die Alster ist ja schon wieder gestiegen. Hör jetzt aber mal auf. Jedes Jahr steigt die Alster. Raus mit der Alster aus Hamburg. Und sie sinkt auch wieder. Aber sie steigt. Raus mit diesem Fluss. Ich mach's auch aus der Stadt. Und dann gehen die los und marschieren Richtung Palast und nehmen alle wie so eine Flut alle anderen mit, irgendwie so Mütter mit so Kinderwägen, die sich nicht manövrieren können. Glaubst du, dass Podcast-Uferhörer solche Multiplikatoren sind? Ich glaube, die Kinder alle so trauen sich nicht, sich anzusprechen, dann nach zehn Minuten gehen sie wieder, weil es unangenehm awkward ist. Ich glaube, Podcast-Uferhörer sind eher so Divisoren, die es schaffen, große Gruppen von Menschen sofort aufzulösen, wie so eine chemische Komponente. Die werden eingesetzt bei Massenpanik und die werden eingesetzt, als die Kurden protestieren wollten in Köln, wurden die eingesetzt. Da wurden die so verteilt, strategisch sinnvoll und innerhalb von zehn Sekunden hat sich die Massenpanik aufgenommen. Weil es allen so unangenehm ist, dass sie alle sich verstreuen und dann so möglichst nicht aneinanderstehen wollen. Hät es uns vor der Love Parade gegeben, wäre das nicht passiert, wir hätten die verhindert. Ja, ja. Das ist eine interessante Theorie. Ich glaube, man kann auch um so ganze Länder abschotten, wenn man so Ketten an Podcast-Ufo-Hörern macht, da kommen die Leute nicht durch, weil es immer so unangenehm ist, da vorbeizugehen. Und die lachen dann immer so unangekündigt oder weinen oder schauen sentimental aus dem Fenster. Was ich krass fand, habe ich heute gelesen, es gibt so ein, in einem Meer gibt es so ein Strudel, diese Strudel, die man aus Filmen kennt, Flugzeuggebung 3 zum Beispiel, diese krassen Strudel und pro Stunde werden da irgendwie 12,8 Millionen Kubiktonnen Wasser reingezogen, was Wahnsinn ist. Und wohin kommt die? Und Forscher nennen das Glory Hole. Nein, wirklich? Das finde ich aber nicht spannend an der Geschichte, ich finde das Spannende ist, dass es wirklich solche Strudel gibt. Ist das nicht mega cool? Aber wo kommt das Wasser denn hin? Ja, das weiss ja halt niemand. Unterirdisch wahrscheinlich. Du kannst ja in einem Wasserglas auch einen Strudel machen, ohne dass das Wasser jetzt außerhalb des Wasserglas... Aber es verschwindet einfach. Es verschwindet unter Erde, unterirdisch. Aber das habe ich mir ohnehin gedacht. In der Erde ist doch bestimmt noch viel Platz irgendwo, oder? Also ich meine, da gibt es ja bestimmt auch Hohlräume oder so ein Shit und Öl und also wir waren ja im Natural History Museum und da haben wir so den Globus gesehen.
Ich war nur in der Cafeteria die ganze Zeit.
Aber währenddessen, ich glaube, ich habe dir auch mal kurz zugewunken, durch deinen Donut durch, da haben wir so einen grossen Globus gesehen, da hat man gemerkt, wie unglaublich unbedeutend eigentlich so die Erhebungen auf der Erdoberfläche sind, so Berge und so, wie scheissegal das ist im Verhältnis zum Rest der Erde, die enorm ist. Und auch das tiefste Meer ist ein winzig kleiner Millimeter Eindellung bei irgendwie einer zwei Meter Durchmesser Erdkugel. Das heißt, das Wasser, das auf der Erde ist, ist ja unfassbar wenig. Das heißt, wenn jetzt einfach nur irgendwo eine Luftblase ist, irgendwo in dieser Erde oder irgendwie eine, keine Ahnung, eine Ölblase oder Gasblase.
Und da ist ein Loch drin, dann wird das alles eingesaugt und ist halt weg.
Und dann haben wir echt ein Problem.
Weil dann liegen die ganzen fucking Seegurken erstmal zappelnd irgendwo im Meer da.
Und ich kümmere mich nicht um die.
Ich kümmere mich sicher nicht um die.
Und dann müssen da irgendwie Schiffe funktionieren nicht mehr.
Die ganze Industrie ist kaputt. Ich könnte einen Fisch aufnehmen, nicht artgerecht.
Könnte ich nur einen Fisch aufnehmen.
Obwohl ich glaube, dein Jeff könnte eine Menge Fische vernichten.
Da können wir uns nichtiffe funktionieren nicht mehr, die ganze Industrie ist kaputt. Ich könnte einen Fisch aufnehmen, nicht artgerecht, könnte ich noch einen Fisch aufnehmen. Obwohl ich glaube, dein Jeff könnte eine Menge Fische vernichten, da könnte man wieder so ein bisschen dem Meer Herr werden, dass man den einfach aussetzt und der kümmert sich da um ein paar fucking Seekunden. Ja, der hat jetzt übrigens so ganz letzte Mal schwarze Punkte, also wenn sich das irgendwer auskennt, dann vielleicht ganz kurz an seinen Flossen und so. Also wenn ihr euch da kurz einschalten könnt, das es relativ dringend Flossenpest. Wollen wir ein Spendenkonto für Jeff einrichten? Ich finde es toll, wie viele Möglichkeiten wir finden, Geld zu bekommen. Bin ich ganz, ganz grossartig. Ja, aber echt interessant. Ich finde es auch immer, wie gruselig es eigentlich ist, dass wir noch leben. Dass wir noch leben alle, ist sehr, sehr viel unwahrscheinlicher als der Fakt, dass wir schon lange tot sein müssten. Na, ich glaube, wir sind schon recht widerstandsfähig, oder? Nee, allein aus solchen Gründen. Jedes Jahr kommen Meteoriten ganz nah an der Erde vorbei. Jetzt heißt es wieder anders, das würde mich ja eh mehr korrigieren, aber die sich so alle 47 Jahre an der Erde vorbeikommen. Und es sind so viele, dass ich mir denke, also das ist sehr unwahrscheinlich, dass wir noch nicht getroffen wurden. Natürlich gibt es immer so Dinge wie der Fakt, dass Jupiter so groß ist und deswegen kommen nicht so viele Gesteinsbrocken auf die Erde und so ein Scheiß. Aber der Fakt, dass wir noch nicht getroffen wurden, ist so seltsam, der Fakt, dass du existierst. Ja. Das ist so Wahnsinn, so viele kleine Figurchen mussten so gesetzt werden, dass du jetzt existierst. Das Leben ist ein grosser Domino Day. Und ganz am Ende des Domino Days, 2011, wo er das letzte Mal stattgefunden hat, ist Linda Demol und das Podcast-Uber, das entstanden ist durch diese ganze lange Reihe an Dingen.
Ja, mega spannend.
Tweet?
Willst du ein Tweet-Rassern? Bei Twitter bist du auch mittlerweile nicht mehr so aktiv, ne?
Überhaupt nicht.
Wie ist das passiert? Keine Lust mehr?
Ne, es ist so ein Phasending, ich habe alles erreicht auf Twitter, ich habe irgendwie viele Herzen bekommen, viele Sachen gemacht. Du brauchst neue Ziele vielleicht einfach. Ich brauche wirklich neue Ziele. Das zieht sich vielleicht so ein bisschen durch mein Leben, dass ich zu früh zu grosse Ziele erreicht habe. Ich habe jetzt meinen ersten Film gedreht, ich habe jetzt meine erste Sendung bekommen und jetzt irgendwie stehe ich hier und denke mir, okay, wo soll das jetzt noch hingehen? J weiss nicht, was ich machen soll, weil alles ist gemacht irgendwie. Das ist das Gegenteil von mir. Da habe ich immer zu hohe Ziele und da arbeite ich immer darauf hin. Was ist denn dein Ziel? Also was, klar, du könntest jetzt sagen, ich würde mal gerne einen Oscar für Drehbuch gewinnen, das ist jetzt aber relativ unwahrscheinlich. Nicht, dass du es nie schaffen wirst, also kann auf jeden Fall stattfinden, aber was ist denn ein Ziel, wo du jetzt wirklich sagst, kann man mal machen? Ich wäre gerne eine anerkannte, eine von mir wichtig empfundene Kritikern anerkannte Unterhaltungsfigur in der deutschen Medienlandschaft. Ich wäre gerne ein gefeierter Komiker, tatsächlich. Da es keinen gefeierten Komiker gibt, weil Komiker in der Regel nicht gefeiert werden, sondern eher gehasst. Gehypt, ich will ein kurzfristig gehypter Komiker in Deutschland sein. In Deutschland ist es ja eigentlich eher so, dass je berühmter Komiker sind, desto mehr werden sie gehasst. Also was sie berühmt macht, ist Hass. Also du kannst sagen, Mario Barth ist der berühmteste Komiker und wird auch am meisten gehasst. Also man kann es ja direkt abbauen. Je bekannter man ist. Nur wenn ich immer berühmte Menschen gleich am meisten gehasst und gehypt, weil es immer halt Leute gibt, die das Hype empfinden und andere, die halt so einen Gegenhype erbauen wollen. Also ich glaube, dass Leute auch polarisieren müssen, die eine gewisse Form von Anerkennung bekommen. Das ist ja das Paradoxe daran. Aber es gibt ja trotzdem unterschiedliche Arten von Hass. Also es gibt ja auch so Promis, die, sag ich mal, auf Hate so ihre ganze Karriere aufgebaut haben oder so auf wen interessieren die denn? So die klassischen It-Girls, Kardashians oder sowas, wo sowohl die Bad-Press als auch die Good-Press irgendwie zusammenarbeiten, wo dann so ein Tweet wie, oh, wen interessiert denn eigentlich überhaupt, mit wem die jetzt einen Sex-Hate gemacht hat.
Genau dieser Tweet ist die Reaktion, die diese Menschen so gross macht. Auch das Aufregen darüber, dass Menschen berühmt sind, fördert ihren Ruhm, weil es weiter so dieses Mysterium, warum sind die eigentlich berühmt, befeuert. Und somit auch jeder Hate, jeder Hasskommentar, für die überhaupt nicht berühmt zu sein, feuert ja weiter das an. Das heisst, es ist ja auch wieder so ein Kreislauf, aber anders als, keine Ahnung, ein berühmter Chillist, den niemand interessiert, der kriegt nichts aus dieser Desinteresse oder Ablehnung irgendwie, der ist einfach egal. Wohingegen andere aktiv gehasst werden. Ich glaube, in der Fachpresse wird der auch teilweise zerrissen. Ja, der wird teilweise wirklich zerrissen, das stimmt. Das war furchtbar da in der Runde. Das warst du? Was war da los, Tag zwölf? Ja, ja. Was glaubst du ist der zu unrecht erfolgreichste Mensch? Cellist. Ach, Gott sei Dank, hast du nicht Cellist gefolgt. Ja, gut, da wirst du nicht sagen. Der zu unrecht gefeiertste Mensch? Ich glaube, das geht per Definition nicht, weil ich glaube, immer wenn man erfolgreich ist, hat man irgendwas richtig gemacht oder zumindest berühmt. Also du musst auch erst mal zwölf Prostituierte umbringen. Das ist auch nicht so leicht, aber dann hast du halt deinen Ruhm. Auf die Idee zu kommen ist ja erst mal nicht so blöd. Breivik, das Breivik-Phänomen. Auf die Idee zu kommen. Ja, ja klar, outside the box denken. Das ist die Frage. Oder denkt man viel zu viel outside the box und müsste eigentlich, ja ist schwierig, wieder in the box schauen. Ist schwierig, ist ja auch das ganze Ding, dass Leute, die, ich glaube, dass Leute, die im Rampenlicht stehen oder Rampenlicht stehen wollen, auch oft einfach ein Problem haben, die wollen einfach geliebt werden und so, aber der Weg dahin funktioniert so nicht. Er funktioniert nach der Mechanik, man will geliebt werden nicht, weil du musst da zu viel, also du wirst, Leute, die im Rampenlicht stehen wollen, werden nicht geliebt. Und das ist ja nur das Paradoxon, womit Leute damit umgehen müssen. Weil die müssen natürlich, ja, um da hinzukommen, halt schon so ein bisschen Narzissmus mitbringen, um sich selber vor die Kamera zu bringen. Und das ist ja per se erstmal eigentlich eine von vielen Leuten als Arroganz ausgelegte Art der Selbstdarstellung. Hast du denn den Narzissmus, den man braucht, um berühmt zu werden? Weiß ich nicht. Manchmal habe ich den, manchmal nicht. Je nachdem, ich glaube, das entwickelt sich auch, je nachdem, wie viel Erfahrung man sammelt. Wenn ich jetzt noch zehn Tage den Podcast machen will, glaube ich, hätte ich das irgendwann, weil ich irgendwann das Gefühl habe, okay, jetzt kann ich es. Und ich glaube, wenn man das hat, wenn man das Gefühl hat, man steht zu Recht dann da dann legt man einen das nicht mehr legt man das als charme aus weil wenn wenn frank elster jetzt dann anfängt werden das zu moderieren dann findet man es cool okay geil aber wohingegen wenn plötzlich jemand so unpaktig von uns sich plötzlich dann vor die kamera stellt und meint werden das moderieren zu müssen dann bin ich immer als arroganz wer bist du das du jetzt meinst werden das moderieren zu dürfen? Da würde man sich aus Arroganz auslegen. Gratwanderung, eine ganz spannende Gratwanderung. Der nächste Anruf war in der Leitung. Wir begrüssen Karl aus Timmedorf. Hallo, Stefan und Florentin, Karl hier. Ja, Karl, was kann man für dich tun? Ja, also mir ist Folgendes passiert. Ich bin heute mit dem Fahrrad unterwegs gewesen und dann plötzlich kam das ist ein Omagio, vier Gang, aber früher mal sieben Gang, aber das war mir dann zu krass. Was ist da passiert? Und dann bin ich da so an so einem Schrank vorbeigefahren und dann ging dieser Schrank auf und da kamen plötzlich ganz viele Fledermäuse raus und die sind mir entgegen geflogen und dann dachte ich mir, huiuiui, mein Gott, wir haben echt so viele Ausländer im Land, die müssen die müssen raus waren die federmäuse eine metapher für ausländer oder sind wirklich federmäuse entgegen gekommen hast du in zukunft vor dir ein schwarzes cape umzulegen um die stadt hamburg ich habe kurz drüber nachgedacht ob ich das mit dem cape machen soll ich we Ich weiss nicht, warum wir jetzt in Hamburg angesetzt sind. Eigentlich sind wir tatsächlich auch erwähnt. Aber, nee, du, das ist eine gute Frage mit dem Cape, das habe ich mir überlegt, weil, interessanter Funfact nebenbei, gestern, crazy story, war ich unterwegs, Oper, klassisch, ich gehe jede Woche mit meinen Eltern in die Oper und waren wir so unterwegs in so einer Gasse, sind also die Gasse runtergegangen.
Ich weiß ja exakt nicht, warum wir ständig durch diese Gasse gehen, weil eigentlich, wir sind wohlhabende Leute und normalerweise die Oper hat ja einen sehr, sehr grossen Eingang, wo die ganzen anderen Leute stehen und wo dann die Limousine vorfährt und so. Everything wrong with Batman in 12 seconds. Also auf jeden Fall alle unsere Kollegen machen das so, da werden die Musinen abgeholt und so und dann die grossen Leute und dann gibt es noch einen Sektempfang. Aber wir gehen irgendwie immer durch diese Gasse raus, irgendwie müssen wir durch diese Gasse und dann liegen da so die Leute in der Gasse und so. Und plötzlich kommt da so ein Typ daher und sagt, Leute, Leute, Leute, was ist denn hier los? Da bin ich jetzt aber richtig falsch abgebogen, lass mich dich erschießen. Okay, und dann lass mich das kurz mal, normale Leute würden jetzt sagen, okay, können wir dir Geld anbieten, weil Leute wollen das natürlich nicht einfach umbringen. Kann ich dir meine teure Perlenkette, ich weiß nicht, ob ihre Mutter Perlenkette hat? Ja, ja, beide. Ob die nicht einfach die Perlenketten anbieten und sagen, okay, ich bringe meinen Sohn hier raus, ich meine, wir sind wohlhabend, wir können bestimmt jetzt schnell irgendwo ein Taxi holen, kein Ding, wir kommen hier, wir wollen hier schnell wieder raus. Vor allem, ich bin ja nicht irgendjemand, meine Familie ist ja bekannt statt bekannt, also die kennt ja jeder. Wie heisst ihr? Wie bitte? Wie heisst ihr? Familienname? Muss er auch nicht sagen. Wir haben das gepiept. Piep, piep, piep, kurz gepiept und ja, also die kennt ja jeder, heißt also jeder, der auf der Strasse ist, würde ja sehen, oh mein Gott, das sind die Piep, Pieps und die kann man jetzt irgendwie kidnappen oder so, naja, auf jeden Fall hat er gesagt, so mein Gott, jetzt ist aber mal Schluss mit euch, ich hab keinen Bock mehr auf dieses ewige Rumgelebe da und dann holt er einen Revolver raus und er schießt meinen Vater, er schießt meine Mutter tot und dann habe ich mich da so zwischen die hingekniet, dann gab es da so eine Szene, dann ist passiert, dass dann das Blut so in so ein Gulli runter geflossen ist, das ist dann so runtergetropft und ich habe mich dann so zwischengekniet zwischen meine Eltern und habe ich so in den Himmel geguckt und dann habe ich so ganz, meine Hände so ausgebreitet, habe gesehen, nein und dann bin ich nach Hause gegangen. Also war ein typischer Tag für dich. Ein ganz normaler Tag bin ich nach Hause gegangen und Scooby-Doo läuft jetzt wieder auf RTL 2 abends und dann habe ich mir gedacht, geil, ist ja eigentlich ganz geil. Die alten Folgen, die eigentlich auch ganz cool sind, weil das Interessante ist ja, dass Scooby-Doo ja immer nur dann Angst hat, wenn er merkt, dass es sozusagen, also er hat ja vor der Maske mehr Angst als vor der echten Person, wo man sich fragen könnte, warum lösen die denn überhaupt das Problem, weil der Maskenmensch ist ein kleineres Problem als das, was sie am Ende gelöst haben.
Und auf jeden Fall, jetzt mit dieser Fledermaus-Geschichte, das lässt mich nicht los. Das lässt mich nicht los. Wir sind gespannt, von dir zu hören. Karl, ich weiß nicht genau, aber das ist nicht ein richtiger Name. Das hast du ja zwar angesprochen mit dem Karl, das ist vielleicht nicht mehr. Vielleicht sollte ich mir da irgendwie langfristig überlegen, ob man da nicht irgendwie Leo irgendwas, Leo in die Richtung macht. Alles klar. Vielen, vielen Dank an der Stelle. Ciao, Ikowski, will nicht von Florian gehört, ich bin ein großer Fan von ihm, aber ansonsten ein guter Mann. Und eure T-Shirts sind echt geil. Ich habe mir jetzt vor zwei Wochen eine Menge T-Shirts gekauft. Ja, die sind gar nicht so teuer, wie alle immer sagen irgendwie. Wie teuer sind die denn? Die kosten 17,99 Euro. Das ist aber erschwinglich. Also vor allem oft bei so T-Shirts ist ja dann irgendwie dieses Granulat, ist ja dann weg nach ein paar Mal Wäschen. Bei mir jetzt gar nicht. Also das ist immer noch da und das kann man auch lange tragen und der Schnitt ist super. Ist 100% Baumwolle, oder? Nee, nicht ganz. Überhaupt nicht, überhaupt nicht. Da ist eine Menge Sulfan mit drin. Aber trotzdem, also von der Qualität her und vom Schnitt her? Och ja, geht. Aber das Motiv ist okay und ansonsten wünsche ich dir noch einen schönen Abend. Oh, ich sehe, wir haben noch jemand in der Leitung. Hi. Liesel Lotte. Hi, Leute. Ich bin Liesel. Hallo, Liesel. Hi. Wie kann ich dir helfen? Ach, ich weiß nicht. Ja. Ich weiß nicht genau, was es für eine Show ist. Soll ich mal ein Problem reden? Soll ich über was cooles reden, soll ich mal ein Leben reden, was wollt ihr hören, ihr beiden? Ja genau, wir haben heute... Ich habe bei Patreon für euch gespendet und ich fand es ganz toll, was ihr mir für den Nachricht geschickt habt. So ein Dankeschön habe ich bekommen. Das ist echt ein tolles Gefühl, wenn man euch bei Patreon spendet. Das ist total geil, das macht richtig Spaß, sondern man fühlt sich auch besser danach. Wollte ich euch nur mal sagen. Ne, wir haben ja heute Thementag Moose und da einfach deine Gedanken dazu. Wir hatten ja schon lustige Anrufer, die ein bisschen ein paar Wortspiele gebracht haben und... Apfelmoose? Genau. Moose-Clues. Moose. Was Moose, das Moose? Richtig, Moose wie der Elch im Ostmenglischen, kann man sich aber zusammenbauen, versteht schon. Moosnagel, Moos-Schmerzen, das hat Hand und Moos, Kopf oder Mo Mus. Von Kopf bis Mus, ja. Es ist doch immer Mus mit lustig, sowas halt. Ja, ich wollte eigentlich von meinem Leben erzählen, das war ein bisschen seltsam. Meine Eltern haben mich damals gefunden. Und ganz seltsam. Wirklich, kannst du dich daran erinnern, wie alt warst du da? Da war ich, ich weiss nicht, wie alt ich war, ganz ganz klein, ein Baby war ich noch. Und dann wurde ich, haben meine Eltern mich gefunden im Feld, in Kansas, ich komme aus Kansas, und dann haben die mich gefunden in so einem Trümmerfeld. Und ich habe auch nicht so eine einfache Kindheit gehabt. Aber nicht so eine einfache Kindheit gehabt, ich wurde oft, ich bin, jetzt glaubt ihr mir eh nicht, das wäre so ein Anruf, den man wie bei Domian auf YouTube findet. Nein, Liselotte, bitte sag's einfach. Ich bin kein Mensch. Ich bin kein Mensch. Ich hab's nicht leicht, ich bin nicht wie jeder andere. Meine Eltern haben mich aus einem Raumschiff gerettet, haben mich großgezogen, ich habe ein bürgtes Fortstadtleben geführt in Kansas. Und na gut, ich habe das Gefühl, ich bin für was Größeres bestimmt. Du klingst jetzt erst mal recht menschlich, ne, also auf den ersten Blick. Wie äussert sich denn das, dieses Nicht-Mensch-Sein? Ich kann Dinge machen, ich kann, also aus meinen Augen kommt Laser raus, ich kann fliegen, ich bin sehr stark. Siehst du den Laser dann auch? Das ist keine blöde Frage. Es wurde mich noch nie gefragt. Ja, ich denke schon, dass ich den Laser sehe. Alles ganz rot plötzlich, aber dann meistens tut es auch ein bisschen weh und dann fliegt oft auch was in die Luft vor mir. Das ist dann, finde ich, interessanter, als darauf zu achten, ob ich den Laser sehe oder nicht. Okay, aber was ist jetzt zum Beispiel, wenn du diesen Laserblick hast und kannst du dann blinzeln währenddessen, würde das dann irgendwie deine Augen? Das würde den Laser dann ganz kurz unterbrechen. Meine Augen hat der Kanadierse gar nichts. Wenn der in die Fliege reinfliegt oder die Sonne blendet oder so. Das ist ganz kurz, dann ist der Laser kurz unterbrochen, aber dann geht der auch wieder an. Wie wird wieder das Camps mit der Taschenlampe davor. Oder wenn jetzt jemand neben dir steht und sagt, oh, guck mal hier. Ja, da muss ich aufpassen. Und dann ist es schwierig. Das machen viele Freunde, im Ulk leisten sie sich daraus, aber da muss man aufpassen. Ja, ich kann viele Sachen machen, ich kann Autos hochheben, ich kann Raster hochheben, ich kann Flugzeuge hochheben, ich kann eigentlich alles hochheben. Und ich bin gespannt, was das Leben noch so mit mir macht. Ja, aber klingt doch erstmal jetzt nicht negativ? Also das mit Lasern ist es immer, oder machst du das an und aus? Nee, wenn ich auch wütend bin, oder auch mal, wenn ich aber auch in Gefahr bin, dann kann ich den Laser aktivieren.
Aber nicht, wenn du vor dem Spiegel stehst, hoffe ich. Das werde ich nicht tun. Aber so wie du aussiehst, musst du ja vor dem Spiegel nicht wütend sein.
Richtig. Wie geht's euch so eigentlich?
Ja, ganz gut eigentlich. Also ich habe das Gefühl, die Sendung gibt es nicht mehr lang, aber vielleicht wird die in den nächsten drei Minuten abgesetzt, aber bis dahin, glaube ich, haben wir noch eine richtig schöne Zeit, ne? Alles klar. Ciao, Ikowski. Spannende Anrufe haben wir heute. Ciao. Flontin, was hast du den nächsten, es geht aufs Wochenende zu, was hast du am Wochenende vor? Das, was ich jedes Wochenende mache. Saufen, bis der Ars kommt. Bei mir Saufen, Fussball. Yay. Sag ich mal. Nee, wird ein richtig geiles Ding. Ich bin mit Jochen unterwegs. Cool. Und wir sind ja auf dem Berg immer unterwegs. Mit den Rudeljungs. Mit meinen Jungs. Und jetzt, ich habe gerade drei Mitarbeiterausweise um mich an. Wir kriegen zum ersten Mal einen Mitarbeiterausweis. Ich habe drei um. Und mit dem Bild auch, oder? Mit dem Bild um. Das heißt, du weißt gerade nicht, welche der drei Personen mit dir spricht. Ah ja, stimmt. Ist das zufällig meine auch mit dabei? Ja, den habe ich dir mitgebracht. Da sehe ich auch ganz schrecklich aus. Das war so eine Nacht-und-Nebel-Aktion, diese Fotos zu, oh, muss ich jetzt eine aussuchen? Bisschen verweinte Augen, Tränensäcke bis zu den Knien. Die müssen es immer tragen, oder was? Die müssen es immer tragen. Wieso Kinder, die verloren gehen und jemanden zu den Eltern zurückschickt, was macht man mit den Kindern eigentlich? Dann sind die halt verloren, da bringt auch eine Adresse nichts mehr. Ja gut, observation kommen die aus den 80er Jahren.
Warum schicken die nicht einfach einen Fax, Mensch, dann können sie wieder gefunden werden. Wolltest du als Kind mal weglaufen, hattest du diese Fantasie, dass du sagst, meine Eltern sind so gemein zu mir, ich darf nicht Detective Conan schauen, jetzt packe ich meinen Rucksack und laufe in die Wildnis? Ich lauf nach. Nee, ich hatte immer auch schon Angst im Supermarkt.
Wenn ich meine Eltern für zehn Sekunden nicht gesehen habe,
bin ich auch komplett ausgerastet direkt.
Da bin ich schreiend durch den Laden gelaufen.
Da habe ich meine größte Angst, verloren zu gehen,
weil man als Kind schon klar war, was willst du denn machen?
Da hast du keine Lebensgrundlage.
Ich meine, du brauchst die halt noch, um irgendwie eine Ausbildung zu garantieren,
einen Job zu garantieren. Ich finde es so gut, dass du als sechsjähriges Kind auch schon gesagt hast, ich brauche eine Ausbildung. Andere Kinder standen so schreiend vor der Verkäuferin und ich stand so ganz adikulativ davor. Ja, also meine Eltern sind jetzt weg und ich weiß nicht, wie in dem Grund alles. Genau und ich habe überlegt, ob man diese Ausbildung zum Steuerberater jetzt mal irgendwie angehen könnte. Ich bin ein Lehrersensiviert? Du wirst auch schon gesiezt, schon sehr früh. Ich wurde sehr früh gesiezt. Ich hätte so einen Potschnitt, quasi so blonde, ich hätte so einen blonden Potschnitt. Hattest du als Kind blonde Haare oder was? Ganz blonde Haare. Warum? Stroblond. Und dann wurde mir... Kann es nicht sein, dass du irgendwie ausgewechselt wurdest oder so und früher ein anderes Kind warst oder so? Ab einem Moment war ich auch plötzlich Bart. So einfach Tag... Und ich hies auch Martin früher. Ja, wenn ich so Every Picture for a Day Ding gemacht hätte, wäre ich irgendwann einfach so Moment mal, das ist von dem 12. auf den 13. April einfach beraten. Das ist aber kein schlechter Sketch eigentlich, so Picture Every Day und ab irgendeinem Punkt einfach eine ganz andere Person, einfach schwarzer Typ, einfach ganz andere so, what the fuck happened at 21. September, so was ist da gelaufen? Also Identitätsdiebstahl, aber festgehalten in Every Picture for a Day. Okay, ich bin jetzt die Person, ich muss auch das machen, was er immer gemacht hat jeden Tag. Das ist aber auch nicht schlecht, du klaust eine Identität von jemandem und merkst dann, oh shit, der macht schon seit drei Jahren so ein Every Day. Ich frage mich wirklich, wie viele Leute dieses Every Day Pictureing gerade machen, weil irgendwie dieser Noah-Typ hat es ja gemacht irgendwie so zehn Jahre lang, mega cool, mega geiles virales Video und so, da haben sich ja bestimmt hundert Leute gedacht, damit fange ich jetzt auch an, aber mach es irgendwie anders, dass ich irgendwie einen Satz irgendwie sage oder sowas oder irgendwie ganz langsam Lied singe oder so. Er ist nur der, der es durchgehalten hat. Ich glaube, es haben tausende Leute angefangen, ungefähr zur gleichen Zeit ungefähr. Ich glaube, meine Everyday-Picture-Challenge hat mal zwei Tage gereicht irgendwie, aber dann dachte ich mir auch, fuck it, was soll das? Ich war meiner Zeit wahrscheinlich voraus irgendwie. Ja, dann hatte ich einen Potschnitt und dann wurde ich immer gefragt, ob ich ein Junge oder ein Mädchen bin. Was einem auch nicht hilft, sich zu finden im Leben. Ja, weisst du, wie es mir ging? Ich wurde immer die Dicke genannt. Das ist auch nicht so cool, wenn du versuchst, einen Platz in der Welt. Aber du weisst, wo du stehst. Ja, ich weiss, wo ich stehe und ich stehe nicht lang, weil ich fett bin. Du stehst fest auf dem Boden. Fetterten einfach. Butterkopf. Ja. Ich war immer lulatschig. Ich war immer lang lulatschig. Freakgröße. Ich war immer zu gross.
Wir sind eigentlich im Grunde echt so dick und lang eigentlich einfach so.
Ja, das war immer schon unangenehm gross und immer ungelenk, tolperstig bin ich rumgewatschelt durch das Leben, Schuhgrösse immer 68 und wir haben die Schuhe nicht in deiner Grösse.
Ja gut, dann gib mir halt wieder die Crocs, ich weiß nicht, die sind vorne offen. Gib mir wieder die Plastiktüten. Gib mir wieder mit dem Gummiband um, Füße schnöre, ist okay. Ja, ich musste halt schon relativ früh, weil ich halt fett war, konnte ich halt irgendwann keine Kinderkleidung mehr tragen, sondern musste Erwachsenenkleidung tragen. Das sah halt immer mega sophisticated aus, weil ich immer schon einen Anzug getragen habe und so. Weil ich dann schon Erwachsenenkleidung hatte, während Anne und ich so Winnie-Pooh-T-Shirt und ich halt Fatty McFat-Sau, halt irgendwie schon in Größe 60, halt irgendwie so ein halb blau Rehen, Polohemden oder so. Bist du Eminem-Fan? Nein, ich trage nur meine Größe. Bist du Kartoffelsack-Fan? Nein, ich trage nur Kartoffeln. Das war so, weil irgendwas brauchst du. Was war das für eine Impression jetzt?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
War die nochmal?
Nein, das weiß ich nicht.
Ich trage nur Kartoffeln.
Ich trage nur Kartoffeln, weiß ich nicht.
Hallo, ein bisschen mitzumitnehmen und dann auf die Hand.
Was?
Das gleiche war.
Ne, das war auf jeden Fall eine harte Zeit.
Oh, früher mal Lateinunterricht, ne?
Oh, das war abgefahren, wo man dann immer ausgefragt wurde.
Ich habe übrigens, wann, ich arbeite schon seit langem an einem Gag. Zu lange. Mein Leben. Und zwar bei Subway, dass die irgendwann, die stellen ja sehr viele Fragen. So will ich mit Twitter auch anfangen. Bei Subway, die Leute, wisst ihr ja, die stellen ja sehr viele Fragen. Kennt ihr, ne? Wie lange dauert es noch, bis die Fragen stellen? Weil jetzt mittlerweile fragen sie auch schon, möchte doppelt Butter drauf, möchte doppelt Käse drauf. Wann sind sie Mitglied in der kommunistischen Partei?
Möchten sie, möchten sie.
Ich sehe eher sowas wie Familiennamen ihrer Mutter, Haustier, diese Fragen, die gestellt werden, wenn man ein Passwort sichert, diese Sicherheitsfragen.
Ist nicht so ganz so reif, aber denkt mal drauf rum.
Gab es nicht früher auch diese McDonalds-Werbung, wo es immer hieß, wo so zwei Freunde zu McDonalds gegangen sind und dann gesagt haben, ah, ich wette, wir schaffen es ohne Nachfrage, wo sie dann gesagt haben, ich hätte gerade ein Big Mac-Menü zum Mitnehmen mit Cola und Eis und Mayo und halt alles, schon alle Fragen vorwegnehmen und dann aber die Kassiererin auch gesagt hat, zum Mitnehmen, wo ich mir dachte, ist das denn so positiv, so ein Lokal, das sich damit rühmt, dass es ganz viele Fragen stellt?
Aber hat sich McDonalds damit gerügt? Ja, das ist ja die Werbung für McDonalds. Also es ist natürlich irgendwo ein netter Gag oder sowas in Richtung, aber ist es denn so? Es ist selbst als Korn. Weil es ist ja eigentlich eher nervig, wenn man selbst, wenn man sich Mühe gibt, das System zu verstehen, immer noch jemand Fragen stellt, also man gar nicht gewinnen kann als Kunde. Ich will bei meinem Sandwich bei Subboy so wenig Salat drauf haben, dass ich habe gesagt, er hätte gerne von diesem normalen Blattsalat und dann hat er diese Geste gemacht, dieses Du kannst mir ruhig mehr sagen, ich bin nicht fähig, das Scherben drauf zu machen. Mehr will ich nicht drauf haben, was eigentlich ein bisschen unangenehm war. Und er so, okay, dann kriegst du es halt so. Das kostet nicht mehr, wenn du mehr Salat nimmst. Was ich bei einem Subboy immer nicht weiss, ab wann schwenkt man um von alles ohne X zu positiv formuliert einzeln aufzählen. Also ich weiss auch nicht, was dem Kassierer mehr hilft, gleich arbeiten ja Leute da draußen bei Subway, schreibt's mal in die Kommis. Also wie wir die denn denken, weil es ist ja ein anderer Denkprozess. Die merken sich ja Dinge und die Frage ist, denkst du die jetzt negativ oder positiv? Ich glaube, du kannst die beeinflussen. Du kannst die beeinflussen, was die für eine Reihenfolge drauf machen, indem du zuerst Tomaten sagst. Zuerst Tomaten darf ich drauf machen, wenn du sagst Tomaten, ja, Blattsalat, ja, du kannst das richtig... Ja, mach doch. Ja, genau, und ich glaube, dann kannst du die auch beeinflussen. Ich glaube, wohingegen, wenn du das negativ beeinflusst, dann gehst du eher das Risiko ein. Die Frage ist ja, ob die das dann nicht umrechnen. Wenn die sagen, okay, ich hätte gerne Tomaten, Salat, Zwiebeln, ob die nicht sofort rechnen. Zwei Euro die Stunde, die rechnen nicht um. Die denken nur, man kann ja nach Hause Scrubs gucken, das denken die. Bei mir ist es zum Beispiel immer so, wenn mir jemand eine Uhrzeit sagt, so wir treffen uns um halb fünf, rechne ich das um in 16.30 Uhr. Ich nehme das gar nicht wahr, halb fünf, sobald es mein Gehirn, mein verarbeitendes Gehirn betritt, rechne ich das sofort um in 24 Stunden Rechnung. In Tackernadeln. In Tackernadeln, ja. Und in Äonen. Das sind 0,001 Äonen. Wie viele TNs sind das? Ja, übrigens sind gerade jetzt die Strassenlichter angegangen. Ich weiss nicht, das ist ein total emotionaler Moment für mich, weil früher bei uns, ich weiss nicht, ob es bei dir auch so war, bei uns war es immer so, wir durften als Kinder immer so lange draußen bleiben, bis die Strassenlichte angehen, was ja ein geniales System ist. Man hätte einfach sagen können. Weil es ja immer an der Dunkelheit hängt. Das heisst, im Sommer dürfen die Kinder, also entweder rede ich oder das rede du oder irgendwie unser Praktikant Juan, der noch gar nichts gesagt hat, aber so geht's nicht. Dona esta Juan?
Juan, wo bist du Juan?
Juan, do moesta a la manja?
Juan, sag es mir.
Juan, mirame.
Juan, zeig es uns.
Das war Spanischlernen mit Stermotiz.
Wenn Sie Italienischlernen mit Stermotiz hören wollen, dann drücken sie die zwei. War das bei dir auch so? Komm mal mit. Mit den Laternen? Ja, bei uns war das so, die haben jetzt mittlerweile die Strassen nicht ausgetauscht, die Strassenlaternen. Das sind jetzt so LEDs. Wie durch die Ranten. Ja, das sind so Fackeln. Das sind LEDs einfach, massiv helle LEDs und es ist taghell. Es ist wirklich unfassbar hell, dass wir so flutlicht was angeben. Man könnte Fussball spielen, das ist so flutlicht so und dann ist es einfach komplett hell erleuchtet. Das ist wie so, wenn man so Dreharbeiten sieht von Filmen, die nachts, wo die die nachts-the-Tag-Szene drehen. So ist es bei uns mittlerweile auf der Straße, das ist so ganz weird. Ist es bei euch auch so, schreibt es in die Kommis, schreibt es in die Infobox.
Nee, schreibt mir nichts in die Kommis.
Schreibt ihr mal unsere Infobox, bitte.
Lass uns mal auf einen Kommentar eingehen.
Okay.
Okay, aber nur auf einen.
Jo, wie wählen wir denn aus?
Nach Stop-Sage-Prinzip oder wie machen wir das?
Ja.
Der Kommentar der Woche!
Stopp!
Wer hat schon?
Ich hab mir vor, Jan Böhmer, wenn du in einem Neo Magazin irgendwann so werb im Gast so, wie lange haben wir schon? Ja, finde ich schon ganz gut eigentlich. Sag ich gleich mal was du. Themen nach hinten stellen ist immer scary. Da reden wir nach dem Essen drüber. Oh shit. Auf der anderen Seite, es kann nicht so wichtig sein, dass man, was man noch warten kann. Von dem User Omo Kiyajaza, die Flug FedEx Delivery, http, www.canadianpricespharmacy.com. Vielen Dank. Ein Bot hat uns entdeckt, ein neues Bot haben wir. Das entdeckt man nämlich immer, weil ich jeden Tag WordPress-Kommentare löschen muss von Bots. Und wir haben ein neues Bot, und zwar bei FIFA gibt es ja dieses Spiel, wo du Karten kaufst. Ich glaube, das heißt Pro. Und da Pro. Und da kann man jetzt Münzen, muss man da kaufen für das Spiel, um das spielen zu können. Und Leute, es ist nicht mehr Viagra bei uns, es ist mittlerweile dieses FIFA. Ja. FIFA-Coins, die man bei uns kaufen kann, was ich so lustig finde. Selbst für die Bots sind wir mittlerweile zu nerdig. Viagra, die brauchen die nicht. Nein, kein Viagra, kein Xanax gibt den FIFA. Also, wir haben einen Kommentar raus. Und zwar haben wir einen Kommentar von Sockel, der schreibt, erstmal herzlichen Glückwunsch an euch, die Folge war jedoch eher so semi-lustig. Ich werde nicht zu kleinkariert sein und auf eine Verbindung zwischen Qualität und Plattform sehen, wegen Spotify. Ich hoffe auf Besserung in der nächsten Woche. Nope. Außerdem erhoffe ich mir durch die vertragliche Bindung mit Spotify, dass sie nun regelmäßig erscheint. Nope. Außerdem würde ich euch gerne die Frage stellen, ob es euch mehr bringt, finanziell gesehen, wenn ich die Folge jetzt immer auf Spotify höre. Nein, tut es nicht, ist komplett egal. Ich unterstütze euch wirklich gerne, falls dies so ist. Nein, kannst du machen, wie du willst. Es verbleibt mit besten Grüßen, Socke. Vielen Dank, Socke. Bist du der professionelleCraft-Spieler Socke? Wenn ja, würde es mich sehr freuen. Ansonsten bist du mir persönlich komplett egal. So, ansonsten. Stefan, was machen wir nächste Woche? Nächste Woche machen wir zum ersten Mal einen Periscope-Stream. Wir nehmen eure Kommentare entgegen, wir improvisieren darauf rum, wir machen Hörspiele bis der Arzt kommt. Nächste Woche wird super. Ansonsten, was gibt es demnächst zu erwarten? Viel Neuerung, viel Spaß. Florentin erzählt seine lustigsten Zuggeschichten. Dann nicht zu vergessen, dass Bess auf in der nächsten Woche. Nicht zu vergessen, nächste Woche kommen 15 Folgen Folgen aus tatsächlich. Bin gespannt. Stefan Titzer hat mich sehr gefreut, vielen Dank für diese fantastische Folge 16 und bis zum nächsten Mal, Stefan Titzer, meine Damen und Herren. Wir heben Ulululup, bis Florin Will. Was? Danke auch dir. Kann man sich nicht mehr Danke sagen oder was? Klar, kann ich nicht mehr Danke sagen. Das ist halt immer nicht so grätzig. Du hast schon das Blubblub gemacht. Dabei habe ich noch gar nicht für mich verabschiedet.
Du hast doch jetzt abmoderiert zwölf Minuten lang.
Wir zählen beide.
Ja, okay, dann zähl.
Wir heben ab.
Blubblubblub!
Mein Gott, ja.